so next game is
set ah Robert Dennis from the USA
well come on let's do
D4 so we've had something similar
before aha okay now knight
taken
I don't know what's right now
Queen B3
maybe yes that's what I thought now
could actually just take D5
or now or not oh so knight D5
D B3 knight
C7 he has he can evacuate the king no
that's stupid because
I don't actually want to play Queen B6
well well we'll have to
do it when we're ready like
that  After all, there are still a few
tempos
so Springer E5 is that an idea
to attack F7, I
don't know, on F6 I could also go to C4,
no,
I'll try
to play a little more directly here. H5, I'm
targeting F7 again, so I mean H4  with the IDE
H5 so now he goes straight to
C2 now I could take F7 ne
or something
make sure that bishop
B4 is almost mated ne so now I thought
maybe G3 with the idea bishop
H3
SO3 so now maybe knight  G5
is attached to H7 and
E6 ck
so we didn't have much of a
choice
so
we had covered so now we have
some interesting
move, well taking H7 is a bit poor,
but it's a bauermer at the end of the day but well
but good with H6 I would
n't like to be chased away either  So
okay, let's
go, that's how it's developing, but it's already developing here.
Now I think it's important that you
play Springer5 to prevent it,
yes, but that's where I wanted to go anyway and
now the idea is now D5
a CD then hangs
E6 you can then  hit well again
Rook C1 is also a pleasant
tempo
yes, that looks very critical for
Black I don't know what he
should move now King D7 t also works
d5oh it's not entirely clear
but I could weaken the C6 here too
just the games where does
B5 go like this and now F zi then he went to
CD5 even win B3 with pieces no yes so
B3 again a minute less it
's
fascinating so well but we've now
won a piece so and still a strong
attacking position  Of
course, yes, I think black does
n't have a great move either. Knight
E4 is good, but if I just look here now,
maybe I have
something stronger, but that
's at least terrible
here
yes now completely
apart there is one more figure and
total
attack
so you can just woh well you can
just take Tower C7 was already
a serious threat so
okay yes
now Jack was
with Jo well that was a
quick 40 points again